it's official there's a new batman game
here
gotham knights um you know just watch it
don't talk about it
dc fandom subscribe click that
notification bell because we'll be
covering more
out of today's event
in breaking news we've received reports
of an explosion
somewhere north of the city
emergency services have confirmed that
they've discovered a body buried in the
wreckage
what is it
waterproof
if you're watching this i'm dead
this message was automatically triggered
when i destroyed the cave and everything
it contained
we both know it won't take long for
gotham's criminals to realize that
batman is gone
um
okay
[Laughter]
good luck and goodbye
good night and good luck
oh nightly plays nightwing
oh we got some red hood batgirl
oh my god all the robins are here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
nice
oh my god that's your boy right there
it's my boy
dude we got it oh
yeah it's give me yes give me that yes
look at the ripples on that cape
oh my god
oh my god whoa
[Music]
cool party
okay like emotional
the court of owls
oh no no
way we're getting the cord of owls
i don't know what happened to me during
this trip you had a rooster
started to get like [ __ ] misty-eyed i
was so
oh my god
for as long as i've known you you have
been carrying the torch for
for nightwing and for the bat family in
general
i used to have to tell people who
nightwing is i'm so happy he's here he's
getting his dude it looks amazing
i can't tell if this is a direct sequel
to the other ones
um i'm not sure about it regardless
though
everything that we're seeing here you
know like you got all the [ __ ] robins
here
todd drake grayson batgirl
what's her name matt barber i've just
been like uh
consuming so much dc content on my own
time lately
and uh rereading some comic books as
well when i revisit some graphic novels
man i forgot how great these are so used
to consuming like the tv shows and
movies now
to go back to some comics and then i
don't know there was something about
this being
like brought to life in the mood and the
tone it was just bringing out some like
weird
wish fulfillment inner child in me that
was just making me get like misty height
on the sun
like i'm just so moved that this is real
now it had the perfect combination of
like really
cool intriguing tone and beautiful
imagery but also i think just having
each one of them get their own little
moment where their logo materializes
around them
like it really does ramp up the
excitement of playing as these
characters
you know because like these games are
well worn now with batman
and stuff and so yeah to like now spread
it out amongst his proteges yeah
it's pretty rad i wonder what they're
going to do with the court of owls in
this game
something sinister my memory is not that
strong on the court of owls um but i'm
definitely familiar with them like
this they're kind of like the masons
secret society that really controls
gotham
they got their hands a little bit of
like are they real you know
but they are in the gotham world they
are and i think there's
rumors that they'll be involved with the
matt reeves one to see them involved in
here
i think is great you know the idea of
like is bruce wayne really dead
maybe is batman really dead maybe but if
he's not to do
a batman game where you're not playing
as batman
but instead you're playing as a variety
of these characters
i'm okay with not playing as batman this
looks pretty awesome
if you beat the game with everyone then
you can just replay it as batman yeah
and make the story kind of funky in on
it
the gameplay does look i mean it goes
out saying like the gameplay looks
freaking awesome the wide variety of
powers i am a little bit more caught up
in the story right now this is pretty
much a story trailer i have a couple of
thoughts
now the one but actually the last time i
really dived into anything court of al's
related was in the gotham show
that i finished uh this this year where
on patreon and then uh so the last time
i really dived into the court of owls
was here and then there was so much with
wanting to get bruce wayne so i'm kind
of wondering
this special boy the prince of gotham
that bruce wayne
is if he faked his own death and is
infiltrating the court of owls
secondly um because at first i i didn't
want to say tim drake right away because
i'm like wait a minute is that
no it's not it's it's gotta be tim drake
i'm wondering
if damian wayne is gonna appear in this
game as well
or at least set it up for damian wayne
to appear which would be
pretty incredible i wouldn't put it past
him at this point now
they know how to hype people up and they
know how to surprise people with stuff
and if that's even
like a whisper or an inkling that you
get off of this i feel like it's
valid to keep it in the back of your
mind but to be able to play as these
characters from the creators of the
arkham games plus i don't know this is
like
[Laughter]
i wasn't expected to be so swept up by
this right now
plus you know you'll get to beat up
gotham thugs and probably like a bunch
of
faceless talons along the way they'll be
your you know faceless henches
put it down as much information as you
want in the trailers
and the comments
honestly i don't know if this could be
top today
well i like i'm also wondering if it is
because like barbara that's barbara
gordon and
you know like she even has her oracle
set up here but she's moving around as
if she was never
paralyzed well maybe you know she's got
some of those lucious fox like those
magic leg braces that he gives bruce in
you know the tdkr and then you know she
can just kick through any wall or pillar
or whatever
yeah oh but man these guys assembling to
take on the court owls
great stuff all right guys this
discussion was a little bit odd
subscribe to the rejects click the
notification bell
uh oh yeah
tyler hague hey tyler you make me a
happy mother effort you know why because
of what the name
tyler means t
stands for tiny
because he makes everyone in the world
feel tiny and caressed y
is for young at heart it's a hyphenate
but but
tyler is young at heart if ever anyone
was you don't need to overexplain
l for loving because that
is the basic way to sum up tyler e
for erect because that's how tyler makes
us feel
and r for rigid erection
what he gives me when i think about him
and now we're demonetized
for this stupid joke thanks a lot tyler
[Music]
you